we are back with Tim Allen everybody
that was a look at his new show on
Disney plus it's called the Santa
Clauses and we are also joined by his
very talented co-star and real-life
daughter now Elizabeth Allen dick y'all
give it up
you did so great and I was telling you
in the commercial but I had no idea I
didn't put it together that you were his
daughter until literally reading the
script for the show and I was like no
way I was like anyway you did such a
great job was it intimidating or weird
to work with your dad
um not really honestly it was a blast
like I had so much fun on set and off
screen like we would finish a scene he
would just immediately crack a joke
about the scene we would just start
laughing but it was just a blast it was
so much fun I I love this it's such a
cool experience to have like with your
kid like enjoying something that you
love doing was it weird for you well I I
always set it up her mom and I
uh we're neutral about her to be in this
business she's really good at school
she's really good in athletics at school
she's really good at math and she's
really good student yeah and then it for
when the Santa Claus we decided to do
this there's a lot of elves in it and I
wanted to make her an elf is a joke not
a joke but if happy Christmas you're
going to go on set and just put on the
ears and wave at Santa so we'll have
we'll have is it a memory yeah you know
a great memory I thought about my older
daughter putting in there but elves at
32 years old seemed a little odd so we
just we put her in there and she said
they said uh if she says hi she has to
read we got to get her voice done so I
I'm the executive producer and I'm
saying I don't want to nepotism aside I
don't want to push that yeah they go no
just have a read it we'll just read the
little part we got here she read it and
the whole room got real quiet and I went
wow and I heard everybody go hmm has she
done this before and I go no but listen
let's read all the other girls let's
just move on move on and she kept
reading up the food chain and one of the
best moments which you read in against
the studio and all the big casting
people the whole the whole place got
really quiet it was on a zoom Edition
and all the boxes literally were looking
at my box and I go uh
and I was doing a fist pump because she
got the joke it was a really subtle joke
with her Mrs Claus yeah and on the way
through it I was on the road and she
called they called her and her mom at
the home says that we'd like her to be
the lead I said I have no way to
describe how she earned it she did it
and she showed great respect for the
crew and the staff and she just drilled
it so that's awesome
um I love that story because a lot of
people would think that you just put her
in there but she worked a way of doing
it again I love that you were like she
got the joke I'm like obviously your dad
how does she not get jokes at this point
until like that would be weird
um but what's the what's the show about
for everybody my I was telling him me
and my kids we loved we saw two episodes
so far it's so great we love the movies
as well so it was so great to see it as
a series like what is it about who do
you play so I play Santa Claus Santa's
daughter and I feel like it's it starts
to dive deep into the family and Santa's
family and how his job can get in the
way of family time and how it really I
mean it does it and there's also people
talk about this more but it answers the
questions that in the old Santa movies
that people kind of started asking about
and that you didn't really ever find out
so there's you know like uh why weren't
the elves mad when just a new Santa
right I show up at the North Pole
they're going okay you got to get these
packages in here and you're thinking did
the other guy die did anybody care about
I loved that part actually well it's
because it was weird in the movies I was
just like well he died he's done like
yeah did he die yeah we don't know we
don't know we can find out and we go
dive deep as it gets later about Saint
Nicholas and the Turkish priest had
started this so it it honors the Heart
of Christmas is about giving it's really
important to understand getting is what
we've got used to but receiving but the
whole thing is about what it's like to
give and boy give as a father to his
children and give to a giver in the gift
gift Getters it is so magic I said I
wouldn't have done it got back in that
that suit just I guess oh my gosh you
saw that uh so I guess so yeah like
walking on set and your dad's Santa I
mean well the first time it was it was
really amazing and I just see him and he
comes around with the whole suit on and
the the full head the beard the
everything and and everyone's just kind
of like up against the walls like this
and just like looking at him is it
incredible it costs
it's like he's a different person but it
was it was really heartwarming at the
same time because it's like all of these
people saw him when they were kids you
know in the in the old movies and now he
comes back on set as Santa yeah as the
care as a character that he's created it
was just it was it's cool it's nostalgic
it's beautiful and my and and kids
forever that's the cool thing about
doing Christmas stuff is like each year
you gain new fans that are old enough to
like start watching them like even my
kids are six and eight and they've been
watching it for a couple years now and
they they because most the time they're
like I don't want to watch a real people
movie they're always like I don't want
real people but they love they love the
Santa Claus movie so they were really
into watching it and it was it was just
really well done thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]